dave and ryan are two computer engineers
and best friends who decide to play the
game of flip the coin on dave's computer
with the computer being the opponent and
ryan decides to observe his game
the computer plays the first move but
dave doesn't know what it was either
heads or tails
now on his turn he can either choose to
flip the coin or not and similarly even
if his results will not be revealed to
the computer
now again the turn goes to the computer
and after playing a few rounds the
computer reveals the result
while observing all this ryan says
hey do you know that there is only a 50
chance that either of you will win
dave got curious he asked how he knew
ryan explained that it's a computer and
he just tried to analyze its moves but
suddenly he says
what are your chances if you play the
same game on quantum computer
dave was confused and asked what is a
quantum computer and how is it different
quantum computers are advanced machines
inspired by quantum physics a study of
the behavior of atoms and particles
so quantum computers operate by studying
and controlling the behavior of these
particles
which in a way completely is different
from our regular computers or even super
computers
it is an upgraded and powerful version
of these computers but not exactly the
next generation computers
like bikes you cannot build a better
bike just by building and adding more
and more cycles together
although they both share almost the same
functioning
dave further questions how does it work
ryan comes forward and explains to dave
that while playing flip the coin his
computer took heads and tails as bits of
0 and 1 and depends on only these two
results
while the quantum computer on the other
hand will also have these possibilities
including a possibility of a mixture of
both heads and tails like zero and one
for example with some portion of zero
and some portion of one
and due to this fluid possibility it
increases the chances of you losing the
game
because whether you choose to flip the
coin or not the outcome will still be
there between both possibilities
just like a mixture of lemon juice and
water
even though the portion of lemon juice
is very little in that mixture you can't
say that it is not there
this property of superposition and
entanglement of quantum physics empowers
quantum computers to handle operations
at speeds that are orders of magnitude
faster than traditional computers while
using a fraction of the energy upon
understanding this dave was mesmerized
by the concept of quantum computers
quantum computers aims to revolutionize
more future quantum technologies
and just like other transformations
around the world quantum computers have
the potential to impact our lives in so
many ways like our security needs
healthcare needs etc
for example it can be used to create
private keys for encrypting messages
from one location to another
it can be difficult for people with
ulterior motives to copy the key of
quantum uncertainty
this type of unique and unbreakable
encryption is already tested by banks
and companies like jp morgan wells fargo
barclays etc
it can be used in the medicinal world as
it will be easier for quantum computers
to study each property of atoms and
molecules as it works on a similar
concept
so
here is a question for you
what makes quantum computers different
from supercomputers
a
atoms and molecules
b uncertainty of outcomes
c
algorithm
d
none of the above
please give it a thought and drop your
answers in the comments section below
three lucky winners will receive amazon
gift vouchers
due to its benefits currently it is
connected to over 17 billion devices
globally
quantum computers are the future of our
coming generations although it is still
under research work it is still taking
over the technology and the business
world
companies like google and microsoft are
competing to build quantum computing
tools
this progress could allow some of the
benefits and insights of quantum
computation to be realized long before
the search for a large-scale
error-corrected quantum computer is
complete we hope you enjoyed this video
if you did a thumbs up would be really
appreciated
here's a reminder to subscribe to our
channel and click on the bell icon for
more on the latest technologies and
trends thank you for watching and stay
tuned for more from simplylearn
[Music]
you